the evil dead trailer scared the living
[ __ ] out of me I cannot believe I'm
actually gonna go watch this movie and
put myself through this terrifying
nightmare The Exorcist looking chick
under the floorboard that right there
did it for me you see I have a thing
about the Exorcist chick she scares the
living [ __ ] out of me and any
resemblance of that freaks me the [ __ ]
out but it's not just that one scary
[ __ ] this film looks extremely bloody
like really bloody I mean season on his
period kind of bloody that moment where
that evil [ __ ] cuts her tongue who I
really enjoy the original Evil Dead it
was really creepy and this one looks to
be the extreme version of the original
it looks like it delivers a horror being
a creep fest show blood best show in the
tree raped her so even though I'm scared
to watch this movie I'm also really
excited for it it looks like one hell of
a gory time that looks like it also
delivers on remaining and entertaining
film we get way too many horror movies
nowadays where they move at a slow pace
to build tension but with the original
creator Sam Raimi behind this film it
looks like it delivers on that clever
entertaining upbeat pneus that is in
every rainy film regardless of the genre
that he's working on I really want to
watch this movie because it's being
advertised as the most terrifying film
you will ever see the thing that was
this it has a lot more going for it than
just being scary I feel like there's
real characters in this movie with
actors I know how to admit real fear and
it looks like the kind of movie that
even if it doesn't terrify you to death
that it will still be one hell of an
entertaining good time I can and cannot
wait for this movie so I'm praying to
God that the evil dead I never thought
I'd say praying to God and evil dead in
the same sentence will get it right
alright people tell me your points below
and if you like the video like the video
and if you want to see more upcoming
reviews go ahead and subscribe to my
channel
all right ladies and gentlemen that's my
chef and if you liked the video like the
video thanks for watching you stay
classy San